Aujourd'hui, je vais vous raconter une histoire
C'est l'histoire de Squeezie en 2013 qui tomba sur un commentaire sur l'une de ces vidéos
Ce commentaire a été posté par quelqu'un qui m'informait qu'il pensais sincèrement que j'avais un trouble du déficit de l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité
Et chose qui m'a traumatisé a l'époque c'était que le mec avait fait une liste de tous ce qui lui faisait penser que j'étais atteint de ce truc là
et vu que des que j'ai un peu mal quelque part, j'ai l'impression que c'est tout de suite un cancer
et ben ce commentaire m'a beaucoup affecté
J'avais fait mes petites recherches, et au final je ne pense pas être atteint de ce trouble, mais je n'en ai jamais eu la certitude parce qu'il faut voir un putain de psychologue pour le savoir
Généralement c'est diagnostiqué quand t'es enfant mais ça peut être diagnostiqué bien plus tard. Pourquoi?
Parce que les symptômes de cette maladie, tout le monde les as. Mais en beaucoup moins fort, je m'explique: je je l'avais préparé ce cours j'ai bossé mon cours vous avez vu!
Les malades sont atteint de trois gros symptômes: l'inattention, l'hyperactivité, et l'impulsivité. Et la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on a tous du mal à se concentrer sur certains trucs, on est tous un peu hyperactifs, on est tous plus ou moins impulsifs!
Donc quelqu'un qui est atteint de cette maladie, des fois il ne le sait pas pendant très très très longtemps
Tout ça pour dire qu'aujourd'hui on va faire un quiz pour savoir si on est atteint ou pas d'un trouble du déficit de l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité
Donc ce quiz il a été fait par des spécialistes du TDAH c'est pas des conneries pour une fois!
C'est pas un quiz pour savoir si t'es plutôt Serpentard ou Griffondor
Mais attention il faut quand même prendre du recul même si ça vous dit que vous êtes atteint du TDAH...ça se trouve vous l'êtes pas!
Ça reste quiz sur internet, faut arrêter les conneries
C'est parti! "Je fais toujours des petites erreurs dans mon travail, je lis vite, j'ai tendance à précipiter les choses"
Petites erreurs: Oui. Je lis: Pas du tout ! Et j'ai tendance à précipiter les choses ça c'est vrai !
Moi dans ma vie je suis hyper speed tout doit aller vite c'est même un truc qui me saoule dans les jeux par exemple dans WoW c'est que je dois aller vite tout le temps tout faire vite
Et du coup je prends même plus de plaisir à faire ce que j'ai à faire dans le jeu, voilà je raconte ma vie
"Je fais foirer mes rendez-vous, j'obtiens des chiffres erronés et j'fais pas attention aux fautes d'orthographes
Ah non, pas du tout moi! "J'ai souvent négliger les détails de remplissage des formulaires ou oublier d'ajouter une pièce jointe à mes e-mails
Bon globalement pour ma part c'est non, je suis un orthographe nazi même si des fois je fais des fautes d'orthographe
Bon globalement, c'est non ça me rassure! "Je suis facilement distrait" ça, dans mon cas c'est très très grave.
Et c'est d'ailleurs ce symptôme là qui m'a fait penser à l'époque que j'avais ce truc
"Je trouve qu'il est difficile de faire des tâches longues, voire même des activités longues, loisirs quoi
Oui oui c'est vrai sauf Overwatch [rires] Ah ça le TDAH il est plus là il est plus rien
"Une mauvaise écoute" Ho putain ça mec c'est chaud "Je trouve que je suis facilement distrait pendant les conversations plus longues"
J'ai tendance à m'éteindre. C'est horrible mais c'est tellement vrai, sauf qu'en je suis avec un groupe de personnes
Où là ça va c'est vrai que j'ai du mal à garder le rythme en fait quand il y a une grosse discussion
"Je peux regarder quelqu'un dans les yeux mais je suis perdu dans mes pensées mon esprit vagabonde souvent"
ça c'est vraiment mais gros avec le truc avant c'est mon gros problème, je n'arrive pas
à rester concentré sur quelque chose très longtemps. J'arrive pas, mais par contre quand je suis concentré sur un truc
c'est vraiment à fond je veux vraiment faire le taf à bloc
Mais ça peut pas durer longtemps même à l'école quand je faisais mes devoirs, je me souviens je bossais 30 minutes
pas plus j'y arrivais pas, mais par contre pendant les 30 minutes j'étais Usain Bolt et j'avais un toc ! Attention dossier, hein !
J'ouvrais mon livre comme ça, (bon là c'est des post-it, c'est un peu de la merde), et je lisais à haute voix mon cours et j'étais obligé de tourner en rond
comme ça je faisais des huit je faisais des serpentins et quand je récitais le cours à ma mère
c'était la même chose et ça la stressait elle disait: "arrête assis-toi" et si je m'asseyais, j'arrêtais de marcher, j'arrivais plus à me
souvenir des trucs voilà c'est vraiment passionnant ce qui se passe bref continuons "je passe souvent à côté
de ce qu'on me dit je dois donc demander aux gens de se répéter" aah c'est l'histoire de ma vie mon gars mais tous les jours c'est infâme
En plus c'est tellement normal quand quelqu'un t'a demandé de faire quelque chose
tu sais que la personne a bien insisté mais tu te souviens plus tu te souviens plus pourtant t'avais écouté
Et là, tu dois lui demandé de répéter
Et tu sais que cette personne va pensé beaucoup de mal de toi.
Elle va pensé que... t'en a rien à foutre d'elle, que tu la déteste ...
Que de toute manière, tu ne l'écoutes jamais, elle ne t'intéresse pas...
Alors, que c'est faux !
Et ce qui est étrange, c'est que mon frère a exactement le même problème
Et du coup, quand on parle un peu de notre vie tout les deux bah, y'a pleins de trucs qui sont similaires
Parce qu'on a les mêmes problèmes, en faite, de comportement
C'est ouf avec mon frère parce que des fois, je lui raconte une anecdote et en faite, cette anecdote, c'est lui qui me l'a raconté deux jours avant !
Mais, j'ai oublié ! Et lui, il fait la même avec moi !
Du coup, c'est vraiment des conversations de demeuré profond
Alors qu'on est jeune, mais pourtant, on s'écoute, je sais pas. C'est pour ça que j'ai vraiment pensé que j'avais ça,
il y a des années parce que au final, je finissais presque par en souffrir en faite
Et je sais que les gens qui ont un TDAH là, les symptômes me font marré
Mais, en vrai, c'est vraiment pas marrant
C'est des gens qui en souffrent énormément au quotidien
Et en plus, ils sont pas forcément pris au sérieux par leur entourage
Parce qu'ils disent :" Mais, c'est bon tout le monde est comme ça, arrête, t'en fais des caisses ! "
Alors que non ! C'est une vraie maladie ! Nan, eux c'est vraiment poussé à l'extrême
Bref, " Je préfère m'y mettre immédiatement plutôt que de suivre les instructions, les guides ou les recettes. "
Ouiii, mais bon, c'est pas excessif.
Je pense que sur ça, j'suis dans la normalité, quoi.
" Je n'ai pas de routines régulières au travail ou à la maison. "
"Je lutte avec les horaires ou les plans."
Oh, si si, moi j'ai une bonne routine de bâtard
Nan, là, c'est pas moi.
" Je ne suis pas obstiné. Je sais quoi faire, je n'arrive juste pas à le faire. "
Ouais... ça, ouais, ça ouais...
" J'ai du mal à m'organiser. "
Oh, putain... ça, c'est vrai..
"J'ai du mal à organiser mon horaire de travail, ma vie sociale et mes obligations familiales."
Euh, nan, Youtube pour le coup, j'suis vraiment... le seul truc où j'arrive à bien m'organisé dans ma vie, c'est ça !
Tel jour, tel jour, tel jour ; Je tourne.
Tel jour : je prend un bain dans l'argent des abonnés
Tel jour, ça, ça va...
J'arrive à m'organiser, j'ai du mal à m'y mettre des fois mais, une fois que je m'y met... je kiffe.
Comme quand tu vas chez ta grand-mère quand t'es petit
Tu cries, tu chiales, t'as pas envie d'y aller...
Et une fois que t'y es, putain, t'es tellement bien.
" La planification d'un gros projet m'intimide. "
Bah, énormément ! Mais, ça c'est tout le monde pour le coup.
Tout le monde, quand tu fais un gros projet bah, t'es intimidé, t'es ...
NORMAL ! Bah, d'ailleurs, j'suis en plein dedans là avec LeStream, donc au moment où je fais cette vidéo, c'est pas encore lancé, ni rien !
J'ai même pas fais la vidéo d'annonce mais..
J'suis comme ça quoi ...
" Je procrastine...", donc je remet au lendemain tout le temps,
" ... parce que je ne peux pas par où commencer ou comprendre ce dont j'ai besoin."
Nan, c'est juste que j'ai la flemme..
100% des humains, c'est comme ça !
On a la flemme, on remet au lendemain, mais nan, c'est pas parce que je vois pas par où commencer
" J'ai du mal à terminer des choses qui demandent beaucoup de concentration pendant une longue période de temps. "
" D'autres fois, j'arrive à me mettre complètement dedans et je suis hyper concentré. "
Ouais, bah, ça c'est exactement ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure...
C'est totalement ce que je fais.
" Souvent, je perd des choses comme mon téléphone, mes clés ou ma télécommande : " Oh mais, j'l'ai vue y'a une minute !! "
NAN! Je suis un nazi, mon gars, sur ça !
La télécommande, je la met toujours au même endroit, les clés pareil !
Et quand, je perd l'un des deux, j'ai envie de tout pété !
Mais, c'est très rare. Donc, ça va.
Je... je casse pas tout, tout le temps.
" Ma maison et/ou mon espace de travail est encombré, y'a des trucs partout. Les choses doivent être là où je peux les voir sinon, je crains de les oubliées. "
C'est totalement vrai, mec!
C'est tout le temps le bordel parce que j'avoue, j'adore voir les choses.
Et quand je les met dans un tiroir, bah, tu peux être sûr que j'y touche pas pendant une année !
Mais vraiment! C'est pour ça que c'est le bordel là, autour de moi.
" Es-tu facilement distrait par des conversations, des bruits ou des activités qui ont lieu autour de toi? "
Ah, ouaiiiiis...
Ouais, ça aussi, c'est un truc que... dont j'ai beaucoup souffert quand je vais au restaurant avec des gens..
J'arrive mieux à comprendre et à écouter les conversations qu'il y a autour !
Qu'a savoir ce qu'il se passe là où je suis avec la personne
" J'ai oublié de faire quelque chose donc, je dois retourné le faire et j'ai du mal à retenir les prénoms. "
Ah ouaiis, de ouf !
Mon gars... c'est une catastrophe.
Et en plus, moi j'ai des TOC de bâtard ! Genre, t'sais le TOC du...
" Est-ce que j'ai fermé le robinet... en partant de la salle de bain, ce matin ? "
Et là, t'es obligé de remonté... T'es obligé de remonté, t'as pas envie de rentrer ce soir et que ta salle de bain soit inondée..
Donc, tu remontes.
" J'oublie les rendez-vous ou les promesses. "
Le nombre de fois où Cyprien m'a engueulé, où il m'a dit :
" Putain mais, Lucas là, t'as ton téléphone de connard de riche... "
" Pourquoi dedans, tu ne notes pas les rendez-vous que tu as ?! "
Ce a quoi, je lui répond : " Oui, pardon Maître roumain. Je vais le faire. " Et j'oublie.
Et quand, je promet un truc pareil, je fais l'effort mais, j'ai vraiment du mal à m'en souvenir.
Alors, je travaille sur moi pour m'en souvenir
" Quand je suis seul, je parle à voix haute à moi-même
pour rester sur la bonne voie "
Alors, ouais, quand j'suis seul, je parle un peu à moi-même.
Ca, c'est peut-être juste la schizophrénie.
Nan, mais ça je pense que tout le monde de temps en temps, parle à haute voix ...
" Alors, j'vais mettre ça là. Là, j'vais prendre ça, je vais le mettre là, ok. "
Ou alors, j'suis le seul.
Et là, j'ai perdu dix milliards d'abonnés !
Alors ? Alors, dis-moi !
J'ai 6 sur 9 !
Un score de 5 ou plus suggère un problème d'inattention,
" Alors que la plupart des gens luttent avec certains de ces symptômes, cela ne signifie pas qu'ils ont un trouble du déficit de l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité. "
" Ils pourraient être stressés par des événements majeurs de la vie ou tout autre problème médical. "
D'accord, donc ouai, moi c'est vrai que je suis hyper impulsif
bon je fais jamais un truc débile, parce que d'un coup je m'enflamme
Mais des fois ouai, je m'enflamme un peu, mais à l'oral quoi
Donc là, mon problème, c'est juste que je suis hyperactif.
et ben okay
Enfin à mon avis, faut que je vois un psychologue pour savoir si je suis un vrai hyperactif ou pas
Mais putain, c'est ouf comme euh...
Même en faisant le quiz, on se rend compte que il y a vraiment plein de symptômes
Que plein de gens ont, tu vois
Et ils en font des caisses alors que des fois, ils l'ont pas beaucoup
À l'inverse, des fois ils l'ont vraiment le symptôme
Mais ils pensent qu'ils n'ont pas plus que les autres, donc ils s'en parlent pas forcément
C'est très très dur
En tout cas, si certains d'entre-vous, ont étés diagnostiqués
ayant un trouble du déficit de l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité, parlez-en dans les commentaires, ça m'intéresse vraiment
Et, franchement, le mec qui a mis ce commentaire, là, il y a 4 ans, il va être trommatisé
J'avais vraiment fais des recherches, des trucs dans le mal mon gars
Et en plus, avec mon frère, on arrête pas d'en parler et du fait que l'on oublie tout le temps tout, on répète sans cesse les mêmes choses
Des fois, on croit apprendre un truc à quelqu'un, alors que c'est cette personne elle-même qui nous l'as apprise deux jours plus tôt
Je pense pas que je suis atteint de sa mais bon, j'ai des petits problèmes de tête  en l'air, de hyperactif, apparemment.
Et bah, n'hésiter pas a aller aimer la vidéo si ça vous à plu
Pour, euh voilà, c'était vraiment une sorte de diagnostic qu'on a fait
N'hésitez pas à faire le quiz et répondez sincèrement, oui ou non
Vous forcez pas à mettre oui, comme vous forcez pas à mettre non, si vous voulez le faire.
De toute manière, si vous avez des doutes, et que vous souffrez de quoi que ce sois
Et bah allez voir un médecin ou un psychologue, ça vous aidera bien plus qu'un truc sur internet
Et je compte sur vous pour envoyer de l'amour aux gens qui sont malades, qui ont un TDAH, ou qui ont quoi que se soit d'autre, un problème psychologique ou n'importe quoi.
J'en suis sur que vous vous en sortez comme des oufs, vous êtes de chefs
Et puis si certains, veulent parler de leurs problème dans les commentaires de cette vidéo, et bah pourquoi pas
Voilà, on fait une sorte de forum quoi [rires]
J’espère que sa vous aura pas trop fait chier,
Je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Moi, je vais prendre cette balance pour peser des fruits, et cuisiner un petit peu, hein
Voilà, tu as encore 4 secondes... C'est bon le placement de produit est fait
C'est pas un placement de produit !
Allez, portez-vous bien, tchao tout le monde
Amour
[musique]